on our democracy an assault
literally on the citadel of liberty
in the united states capital itself
an assault on the rule of law
an assault on the most sacred of
american undertakings
ratifying the will of the people
and choosing the leadership of their
government
all of us here grieve the loss of life
grieve the desecration of the people's
house
but we what we witnessed yesterday was
not dissent
it was not disorder it was not protest
it was chaos they weren't protesters
don't dare call them protesters they
were
a riotous mob insurrectionist
domestic terrorist it's that basic it's
that simple
and i wish we could say we couldn't see
it coming
but that isn't true we could
see it coming the past four years we've
had a president
who's made his contempt for our
democracy
our constitution the rule of law
clear in everything he has done
he unleashed an all-out assault
on our institutions of our democracy
from the outset
and yesterday was about the culmination
of that unrelenting attack
he's attacked the free press who dared
to question his power
repeatedly calling the free press the
enemy of the people
language at the time he first jews and i
and others said
has long been used by autocrats and
dictators
all over the world to hold on to power
the enemy of the people language
that is being used now by autocrats and
dictators across the world
only this time with the imperative of an
outgoing
president of the united states of
america
he's attacked our intelligence services
who dared tell the american people the
truth
about the effort of a foreign power to
elect him four years ago
choosing instead to believe the word of
vladimir putin
over the word of those who've sworn
their allegiance
into this nation many of whom
had risked their lives in the service of
this nation
he deployed the united states military
tear-gassing peaceful protesters in
pursuit of a photo opportunity
in the service of his reelection even
holding the bible
upside down the action
that led to an apology from the chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff
and an outspoken denunciation
of the use of military for domestic
political purposes
from scores scores of former military
leaders
and secretaries of defense led by
secretary
cheney he thought he could stack the
courts
with friendly judges would support him
no matter what
they were trump judges his judges
he went so far as to say he needed nine
justices on the supreme court because
because he thought the election would
end up in the supreme court
and they would hand him the election
he was stunned truly stunned
when the judges he appointed didn't do
his bidding instead acted with integrity
following the constitution upholding the
rule of law
not just once or twice or three times
but over
60 times let me say over 60 times
in more than 60 cases in state after
state after state
and then at the supreme court judges
including people considered
quote his judges trump judges
use his words looked at the
allegations that trump was making and
determined they were without
any merit
nothing was judged to
put this election in question or doubt
by any of these judges
you want to understand the importance of
democratic institutions this country
take a look at the judiciary in this
nation
take a look at the pressure it was just
subjected to
by a sitting president of the united
states of america
at every level the judiciary rose of the
moment during this election
did its job acted with complete fairness
and impartiality
with complete honor and integrity
when history looks back in this moment
as just we've just passed through
i believe it will say our democracy
survived in no small part
because of the men and women who
represent an independent judiciary in
this nation
we owe them a deep deep debt of
gratitude
and then there's the attack on the
department of justice
treating the attorney general as his
personal lawyer in the department as his
personal law firm
through it all we would hear the same
thing from this president my generals
my judges my attorney general
and then yesterday a culmination of
attack on our institutions of democracy
this time the congress itself
inciting a mob to attack the capital to
threaten elected representatives
of the people of this nation and even
the vice president
to stop the congress from ratifying the
will of the american people
in a just completed free and fair
election trying to use a mob
to silence the voices of nearly 160
million
americans who summoned the courage
in the face of a pandemic that
threatened their health
and their lives to cast that
sacred ballot
i made it clear from the moment i
entered this race
that what i believe was at stake i said
there was nothing less
at stake than who we are as a nation
what we stand for
what we believe what we will be
at the center of that belief is one of
the oldest principles this nation
has long held we are a government of
laws
not of men not of the people
of laws i said it many times in the
campaign
our democratic institutions not relics
of another age
they're what sets this nation apart
they're the guardrails of our democracy
and there's no president that's why
there is no president
who is a king no congress
that's a house of lords a judiciary
doesn't serve the will of the president
or exist to protect him or her
we have three co-equal branches of
government
co-equal
our president is not above the law
justice
serves the people it doesn't protect the
powerful
justice is blind what we saw
yesterday in plain view was another
violation of the fundamental tenet of
this nation
not only did we see the failure to
protect one of the three branches of our
government
we also saw a clear failure to carry out
equal justice
i'm sure he used to say in the senate
excuse a point of personal privilege
a little over an hour and a half after
the chaos started i got a
text from my granddaughter finnegan
biden who's a senior
in her last semester at the university
of pennsylvania
she sent me a photo
of military people in full
military gear scores of them
lining the steps of the lincoln memorial
because of protests by black lives
matter
she said pop this isn't fair
no one can tell me that it had been a
group of black lives matter protesting
yesterday
there wouldn't have been they wouldn't
have been treated very very differently
than the mob of thugs that stormed the
capitol
well we all know that's true and it is
unacceptable
totally unacceptable the american people
saw a plain view
and i hope it's sensitized into what we
have to do
not many people know it when justice
carl and i were talking we talked about
i think he raised it
the reason for the justice department
was formed in the first place
was back in 1870 we didn't have a
justice department before that cabinet
it was formed in 1870 to enforce the
civil rights amendment that grew out of
the civil war
the 13th 14th and 15th amendments
to stand up to the klan to stand up to
racism
to take on domestic terrorism
this original spirit must again
guide and animate its work
so as we stand here today we do so in
the wake of yesterday's events
events that could not more have vividly
demonstrated
some of the most important work we have
to do in this nation
committing ourselves to the rule of law
in this nation
invigorating our domestic and democratic
institutions
carrying out equal justice under the law
in america
there is no more important place for us
to do this work than the department of
justice has been so politicized
there's no more important people to
carry out this work
than the people i am announcing today
more than anything we need to restore
the honor
the integrity the independence
the department of justice in this nation
has been so
badly damaged and so many former leaders
of that department and both parties
have so testified and stated that
i want to be clear to those who lead
this department
who you will serve
you won't work for me you are not
the president or the vice president's
lawyer
your loyalty is not to me
it's to the law the constitution
the people of this nation to guarantee
justice
for attorney general of the united
states
i nominated a man of impeccable
integrity
judge merrick garland one of the most
respected jurists of our time
brilliant yet humble distinguished yet
modest
full of character and decency
a supreme court clerk served in the
justice department during the carter
bush 41 and clinton administrations
where he embraced the department's core
values of independence and integrity
a federal prosecutor who took on
terrorism and corruption and violent
crime
always with the utmost professionalism
and the duty
to the oath he swore
nominated by president clinton to be a
judge on the d.c
circuit court of appeals considered the
second most powerful court in america
throughout such a long and distinguished
career
judge garland has earned the praise and
admiration of members of
bench and barr and politicians of both
parties
and despite his busy schedule and
prestigious positions
he still makes time to volunteer
regularly tutoring students in northeast
dc
as he's done for 20 years it's about
character
it's about character
it was no surprise why president obama
nominated him
judge garland to the supreme court
as i said he embodies honor decency
integrity fidelity to the rule of law
and judicial independence to those same
traits
he will now bring as attorney general of
the united states
not as a personal eternity to the
president but as the people's lawyer
he'll restore trust in the rule of law
and equal justice under the law and i
fully expect
discussions i've had he will receive a
fair hearing and swift confirmation
and once he's confirmed i will move
promptly
to nominate his replacement on the d.c
circuit court of appeals
and i expect that the distinguished
nominee will receive a prompt and fair
hearing as well
for deputy attorney general i nominate
one of the most selfless people i've
worked with
one of the brightest i've worked with i
worked with her during the last
administration
a 15-year veteran of the justice
department
lisa monaco lisa knows the department
inside and out
she has a definition of what a public
servant should be
decent trusted honorable
and i might add i embarrassed her a
moment ago with other colleagues
and selfless i offered her other
positions
of greater consequence quote unquote
more prestige
but she wanted to work with you judge
she wanted to go back to the justice
department
a top-flight prosecutor who took on
public corruption
corporate fraud and violent crime
chief of staff the director of the fbi
the first woman ever confirmed as
assistant attorney general for national
security
where she elevated cyber security to a
top priority
and where it's even more consequential
today than it was then
at the white house she was the top
homeland security and counterterrorism
advisor
to president obama and me in every one
of the national security meetings
she coordinated our fight against
al-qaeda and isil
she helped lead our response to the
ebola crisis
when the bombs went off at the finish
line on patriots day in boston
her hometown she coordinated the federal
government's response
with local and state law enforcement to
get to the bottom of this horrible
tragedy lisa i know
i know you will help restore integrity
and independence
of the department of justice that you so
revere
as associate attorney general the number
three job at the department
i nominate anita gupta
a woman i've known for some time one of
the most respected civil rights lawyers
in america
started a career at the naacp legal
defense fund
then on to the aclu both organizations
to which i belong
and then to the justice department
during the obama body administration
where she led the civil rights division
at every step with every case
she fought for greater equity and the
right to right the wrongs of a justice
system
where they existed
and she's done so by bringing people
together earning praise from across the
ideological spectrum
for her approach to solving some of the
thorniest problems we face
during the obama biden administration
veneta
was put in charge of investigating the
abuse of power in police departments in
ferguson missouri
and other communities torn apart by acts
of violence and racial injustice
she helped institute common sense police
reforms
to build greater equity safety and trust
she was commended for her work by both
law enforcement and those advocating
for changes in the criminal justice
system
that's a rare achievement and it speaks
volumes about her capacity
to unite people in common purpose which
is what this is
all about uniting the american people
born in philadelphia a proud daughter of
immigrants from india that sound
familiar
if confirmed bonita will be the first
woman of color to serve as associate
attorney general
and i'm grateful i'm grateful if anita
is
leaving her current job leading one of
the premier civil rights organizations
in the world
as she answers the call to serve once
again to ensure that our justice system
is even more fair and more equitable
thank you
for assistant attorney general for civil
rights i'm nate
i nominate kristen clarke who has
spent her career advocating for greater
equality and equity
in our justice system the daughter of
jamaican
immigrants now don't think this has been
designed here
i'm still looking for an irishman all
kidding aside
the daughter of jamaican immigrants
kristin is also one of the most
distinguished civil rights attorneys in
america
a proud native of brooklyn new york she
began her career
her legal career in the very same office
she's now
nominated to lead her previous tenure
with the justice department saw her take
on some of the most complex civil rights
cases from voting rights
to redistricting challenges to
prosecuting hate crimes and human
trafficking she's earned accolades
throughout her career
including as the head of the civil
rights bureau
for her home state of new york where
she's led
the charge to end the school-to-prison
pipeline and root out discrimination
in housing and in law enforcement she
currently leads one of the
nation's top civil rights organizations
where she promotes greater equity
in voting rights in our education system
and our housing system and our justice
system and so much more
now she'll return full circle
to pursue the vital work where her
career began
the civil rights division represents the
moral center
of the department of justice and the
heart
of that fundamental american ideal
that we're all created equal and all
deserve to be treated equally
i'm honored you've accepted the call
to return to make real the promise for
all americans
to each of you i thank you for your
service
and to your families and to the american
people
this is a team that will restore your
trust and faith in our institutions
of democracy i chaired the judiciary
committee for many years
one of my goals in running in the first
place
you may recall i said when i saw those
people coming out of the fields in
charlottesville
shouting hate
young woman killed
and when asked the president said there
are good people on both sides
that's literally why i ran
there's no more important
and heartfelt effort on my part
than restoring restoring the
independence and integrity
about your our justice department so may
god bless you all may god protect
our troops and those who are sworn to
protect the american people
now i will turn it over to the team
starting with the next attorney the
united states
attorney general of the united states
judge merrick carl
thank you
thank you president-elect biden vice
president-elect harris
for asking me to serve as the attorney
general
of the united states thanks always
to my wife children sisters late parents
without whose insist unstinting support
i would not be standing here today
thanks also to my grandparents whose
decision to undertake the difficult
journey to america
made all things possible for my family
if confirmed i look forward to working
with these wonderful doj veterans
lisa monaco benita gupta and kristen
clark
entering the department of justice will
be a kind of homecoming for me
my very first job after serving as a
judicial law clerk
was to work as a special assistant to
then attorney general
ben civiletti ed levy
and griffin bell the first attorneys
general appointed after watergate
had enunciated the norms that would
ensure the department's adherence to the
rule of law
attorney general civiletti undertook
to continue their work of crafting those
norms
into written policies those policies
included
guaranteeing the independence of the
department
from partisan influence in law
enforcement investigations
regulating communications with the white
house
establishing guidelines for fbi
investigations
ensuring respect for the professionalism
of doj's lawyers
and agents and setting out principles to
guide
the exercise of prosecutorial discretion
those policies became part of the dna
of every career lawyer and agent
if confirmed my mission as attorney
general
will be to reaffirm those policies as
the principles
upon which the department operates
as ed levy said at his own swearing-in
nothing can more weaken the quality of
life
or more imperil the realization of the
goals we
all hold dear then our failure to make
clear by words indeed
that our law is not the instrument
of partisan purpose in the decades that
followed my first curve duty at the
department
i returned again and again in different
roles
as a career line assistant u.s attorney
as a criminal division supervisor
and finally as a senior official in the
office of the deputy attorney general
in the latter role i worked with every
component of the department
on issues ranging from civil rights and
antitrust
to domestic terrorism and national
security
i also work directly with line
prosecutors and agents
in offices from oklahoma city to
billings montana
from sacramento california to new york
city
attorney general later supreme court
justice robert jackson family
famously said the citizens safety
lies in the prosecutor who tempers zeal
with human kindness who seeks truth
and not victims who serves the law
and not factional purposes
and who approaches his job
with humility that was the kind of
prosecutor i tried to be
during my years of service at doj
in 1997 i left the department to serve
the cause of justice in another role
as a judge i have loved being a judge
but to serve as attorney general at this
critical time
to lead the more than 113 000 dedicated
men
and women who work at the department to
ensure the rule of law
is a calling i am honored and eager
to answer as everyone who watched
yesterday's events in washington now
understands if they did not
understand before the rule of law
is not just some lawyer's turn of phrase
it is the very foundation of our
democracy
the essence of the rule of law is that
like cases
are treated alike that there not be one
rule for democrats
and another for republicans one rule for
friends
another for foes one rule for the
powerful
another for the powerless one rule for
the rich
and another for the poor or different
rules
depending upon one's race or
ethnicity and the essence
of its great corollary equal justice
under law
is that all citizens are protected in
the exercise of their civil rights
those ideals have animated the
department of justice
since the very moment of its inception
as president-elect biden just recounted
the department was founded in the midst
of reconstruction
following the civil war with its first
principal task
to ensure compliance with the 13th
14th and 15th amendments
as historian ron chernow wrote quote the
new justice department would forge its
identity
in the battle to slay the first
incarnation
of the ku klux klan and its offshoots
in that battle the department
successfully deployed its considerable
resources
to ensure civil rights which were under
militant attack
these principles ensuring the rule of
law
and making the promise of equal justice
under law
real are the great principles upon which
the department of justice was founded
and for which it must always stand
they echo today in the priorities that
lie before us
from ensuring racial equity in our
justice
system to meeting the evolving threat
of violent extremism if confirmed
those are the principles to which i will
be devoted
as attorney general president-elect
biden
understands this as he said today and as
he has publicly said before
quote it's not my justice department
it's the people's justice department he
promised that the person he chose to
lead the department would have the
quote independent capacity to decide
who gets prosecuted and who doesn't
vice president-elect harris has also
publicly stated quote
any decision coming out of the justice
department should be based on
facts should be based on the law
it should not be based on politics
period i could not agree more
and i would not have agreed to be
considered for
attorney general under any other
conditions
so thank you both for giving me the
opportunity
to serve
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
thank you for this opportunity to return
to the department of justice and to work
alongside this incredible
team on behalf of the american people
i also want to thank my family
for their love and support and
especially my parents
for their lessons large and small
in what it means to live one's values
it's fair to say that i grew up in the
justice department
it was my privilege for 15 years
to serve that institution and to learn
so much
from its extraordinary people to learn
what it means to be a lawyer
in public service and over the years i
have worn many hats
as a career prosecutor as a senior
official
in the fbi and as a leader of the
national security division
but it was as an assistant u.s attorney
that i learned the justice department's
values
i worked directly with communities and
victims of crime
and i felt the weight of a prosecutor's
responsibility
to ensure not that cases are won
but that justice is done
and that each individual defendant's
rights
are protected these experiences
forged in me a reverence for the
department of justice as an institution
for its people for its mission
for the enduring values that it
represents
the protection of civil rights and civil
liberties
safeguarding the public from threats of
all kinds
and upholding the rule of law
merrick's mention of former attorney
general edward levy
calls to mind one of my earliest
memories
as a doj lawyer my first job in the
department
was as counsel to janet reno the first
woman
attorney general a mentor to me and a
trailblazer
in the conference room outside her
office she hung
a portrait of ed levy a tribute to his
role
in reaffirming the integrity and
independence of the institution after
watergate
and i think she hung that portrait as a
testament of sorts
to the fact that we are all temporary
custodians
of the institution the story goes
that when president ford asked levy
what he thought the department needed
most
in those days of flagging faith in
institutions
levy responded a soul
well the soul of the justice department
lives in the integrity of its career
professionals
in the independence of its
investigations and prosecutions
and in the principles it brings to bear
as it stewards
the ideal of justice in america
today we are at another inflection point
some of the challenges we face are
familiar
racial inequality the need for criminal
justice reform
domestic terrorism and threats to public
safety
some of the tasks are enduring
like the importance of working closely
with law enforcement
to ensure public safety and to build
trust in our communities
some of the challenges are evolving
like mounting cyber threats i'm
confident that the department of justice
is up to all of these challenges
but what is most critical i think in the
days ahead
is not actually a challenge at all but
an opportunity
for this team and for the career
professionals who make
up the justice department to reaffirm
its norms and traditions to do justice
without fear or favor
to keep the american people safe and to
do so
always consistent with the rule of law
if confirmed it will be my honor
to once again work alongside the women
and men
of the justice department as custodians
of a remarkable
and durable institution mr
president-elect madam vice
president-elect
thank you for the opportunity to return
home
to the department of justice
mr president-elect madam vice president
thank you for the opportunity to serve
this nation
i want to thank my family and my parents
who taught me early on the values that
have led me to civil rights work and
public service
i am humbled and honored to return to
the department of justice
it is an institution that i love so so
dearly
and to once again work alongside the
exceptional
women and men who every day defend the
constitution
enforce our federal laws and seek to
create
a more perfect union with deep integrity
and without political interference
there are many agencies in the federal
government but actually only one that
bears the name
of a value by virtue of that name
that value of justice we
know the department carries a unique
charge
in north star at its best
it is the keeper of a sacred promise
it's the promise of equal justice
for all that no one is above
the law and when this promise is pursued
with vigor
it brings light to our nation and serves
as a beacon
to the world but when abandoned
we degrade our democracy and so the
division that we've come to know
all too well the first time i felt the
absence of that promise was as a
four-year-old child one of my earliest
memories
my parents were proud immigrants from
india an opportunity that was made
possible by the civil rights movement
and the 1965 immigration and nationality
act
one day i was sitting in a mcdonald's
restaurant with my sister
mother and grandmother and as we ate our
meals a group of skinheads at the next
table began
shouting ethnic slurs at us throwing
food at us
until we had to leave the restaurant it
is an early memory
but one that is seared in my mind that
feeling never left me
of what it means to be made to feel
unsafe because of who you are
i kept another feeling with me though
too and that is one that has been
ingrained
in me by my parents and shared by my
husband
whose family fed fled violence and war
in vietnam
and sought refuge on these shores they
believed more than
anything in the promise of america and
that
loving this country brings with it the
obligation
to do the necessary work to make it
better
those two feelings for me converge in
the work ahead of us
yesterday's horrific events at the
capitol reminded us
that our democracy cannot be taken for
granted
that our nation has a long history of
disinformation
white supremacist violence mob violence
it also reminded us that our values and
our constitution
and our democracy these do not protect
themselves
it is people with courage who do that
and i am honored to return to a
department
that i know will push every day for
justice
accountability and equality under the
law
it will not be enough to restore what
has been undermined
or lost this moment demands bold
leadership
the department of justice as it is done
throughout
its storied history will have to uncover
and reckon with hard truths hold people
companies and institutions accountable
to our constitution
and laws drive change where there is
injustice
and heal a nation that is starving for
leadership
and decency and hope
now is the time to ensure that our
economic system works for
everyone that we can protect the health
and safety of all of the american people
and that we will harness all of the
justice department's levers for civil
rights
justice and police reform and climate
justice and so much more
as the late congressman john lewis said
democracy is not a state
it is an act and i pledge to the
american people that if confirmed i will
act for justice
every day i pledge that to you
president-elect
i pledge that to you vice
president-elect
i am honored deeply honored for the
chance to work together
with activists for justice with law
enforcement with this
extraordinary team that i'm so humbled
to serve
with the incredible women and men at the
justice department
to strengthen our democracy and to make
equal justice
under law a real promise for all thank
you so much for this opportunity
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
it's an honor and a privilege to be
nominated to return to the department of
justice and serve the american people
at this critical moment in our democracy
i am humbled and exceedingly proud
to join the remarkable team that you
have put together
to pursue the urgent timeless cause
equal access to the extraordinary
opportunities
of american life will he be able to
embrace those opportunities
in safety and dignity
will all of america's children
every parent lays awake some nights
asking these same questions i know that
my own parents did
i was fortunate to benefit from amazing
educational opportunities
and plenty of lucky breaks that opened
doors for me
but i know then as i know today
that not everyone is blessed with the
opportunities
that i enjoyed and that awareness has
animated my life's work it's what
brought me to the department of justice
where i started my career and it's what
brings me back
for this homecoming today the department
and especially the civil
rights division has always occupied a
special
place in my heart the clarion
call of equal justice under law is what
binds us together as a nation
now it's my honor to return to work
alongside the dedicated career
professionals who give
of themselves every day to make that
principle
real in the lives of families like mine
in my son's life and in the lives of all
of our sons and daughters i know the
passion
and fearlessness that both the
president-elect
and the vice president-elect bring to
the work
before us to restore justice
to heal our nation and to move us
closer to that ideal of equal justice
i'm humbled honored and eager
to work with them and with this team
thank you for giving me this opportunity
to serve
my country as a member of your
administration
one of the fundamental principles upon
which america's democracy rests
a principle as sacred as a civic value
can be
is fidelity to the rule of law
in times of stability that principle
can seem abstract like something out of
a legal textbook that isn't relevant to
our daily lives
but in times of upheaval we come to
realize
to appreciate just how vital the rule of
law truly
is what we saw yesterday
in our nation's capital was as the
president-elect
has called it an assault
on the rule of law and it has no place
in our democracy
so i believe we must ask ourselves two
questions
about what happened yesterday
what went wrong and how do we make it
right and i believe the answers require
us to recognize
that the challenge we're facing in our
country
is about more than the actions of the
few
we watched yesterday it's about
how to reform how to
transform a justice system
that does not work equally for all
a justice system that is experienced
differently depending on whether you're
white
or black a justice system
that is experienced differently
if you're rich or poor
a justice system that's different
depending on whether your job requires
you to take a shower before you go to
work
or requires you to take a shower when
you come home after work
we witnessed two systems of justice
when we saw one that let extremists
storm the united states capital
and another that released tear gas
on peaceful protesters last summer
the american people have expressed
brightly
outraged we know
this is unacceptable we know
we should be better than this
the promise of our country is that all
people
will be treated equally that's what the
rule of law is supposed to be
about that's what the ideal
of equal justice under law
is all about like everyone here
i've dedicated my career to helping
uphold those principles
to attempting to uphold those principles
to helping
build a more just and equal america
whether it was
as san francisco's district attorney or
california's attorney general
or a united states senator and that's
what i have pledged to the
president-elect
that i will do as vice president
the public servants we are announcing
today
have also dedicated themselves to
building a more just
and equal america and the roles they
will assume
are some of the most important in our
country
and especially right now
they will be responsible for pursuing
justice
and ensuring that all americans are
treated equally
they will be the guardians of our
justice system
they will have the power to enforce our
laws
in a more fair and more humane manner
while also holding those who violate the
law accountable
whether they be ordinary citizens or law
enforcement
they will help protect the rights of
every voter
in our country no matter what their
background or where they live
and they will restore integrity
and independence to the department of
justice
and rebuild the american people's trust
in that most sacred institution and i
know they will do this
because these nominees have the
experience
the judgment and moral compass that
these roles demand
as well as an abiding commitment to
supporting and defending
the constitution of the united states of
america
for many centuries the ideal of justice
has been symbolized as a woman
blindfolded with a scale in her hands
there is a reason the eyes of that lady
justice
are covered it's because
our belief in what a system of justice
is says that it should not depend
justice should not depend on how you
look
on the color of your skin on how much
money you make
it shouldn't depend on where you were
born or the language your grandmother
speaks
or what political party you belong to
justice should be impartial
it should be fair it should be applied
equally and president-elect biden and i
along with this incredible team will
help to make sure it is
while restoring and strengthening the
rule of law
that has always been and always will be
the bedrock of america's democracy
thank you mr president-elect
donald trump be prosecuted for inciting
a riot
[Music]
let's go guys